do you think there's a chance there's a
world in which she's able to modulate it
enough to be a unifier and run for
president
and win I think she's very far away from
being able to do that
I think that
um
even other politicians that are also
polarizing within the squad in terms of
what they say or their ideas whatever
else
are very effective communicators like
ilhan Omar and others
um
I think I think AOC I mean that's my
hope right my hope is that someone like
AOC
um could uh the last year plus have not
has not been extremely promising you
know in my in my mind in part because
she's become or she's continued to
position herself as a lightning rod
cultural
figure
whereas I think a national political
figure needs to pick their spots and
also pick their moment for changing
their their rhetoric and adjusting to
Their audience and I think she does it
in certain environments but that needs
to be your National message when you're
out there
um you need to be speaking towards the
not already
um converted and I think Bernie does
that Bernie strips his politics down to
the basics
so I agree with you spiritually but I
also we also have an example of Donald
Trump winning the presidency
isn't some
isn't some of the game of politics
that's separate from the policy
being able to engage in rhetoric that's
that leads to outrage and then walking
through that fire with Grace
first of all I think Trump was is kind
of a unique personality in American
history so it's hard to to
to compare anyone to to Trump but don't
you think AOC is comparable in terms of
the uniqueness
in the political system we're in or no
much more of a Firebrand
anti-establishment Force
um
in that and I mean this negatively for
what it's worth because I you know
disagree with Trump but he was willing
to set fire to the Republican
um uh establishment right uh he was able
to self-fund you know largely his
campaign and he already was a media
figure without them uh AOC has been much
more cautious for the Democratic party
establishment in part because she's not
trying to run a national political
campaign right now for the outside like
a five percent chance to be president
let me set fire to everything she's
trying to help people and help her
constituents through the game of getting
committee appointments and you know
getting wins in the margins and I think
that's understandable for what it's
worth but in the process I think
what's the difference between AOC and a
progressive Democrat during 2016 it used
to be pretty easy to say the difference
between the Bernie Kratz and a
progressive Democrat right because we
were establishing our own outside third
force in American politics
were you know you could knock on the
door of a lot of people who would end up
voting for Trump and they would say oh I
have a lot of respect for for Bernie or
whatever they're still gonna not vote
for him but he wasn't considered part of
the democratic party milieu
um I think now with AOC there's a much
closer Association of AOC in our
policies with ordinary
Democrats where she needs to draw
stronger distinctions she does need to
do it like um Trump did with just man I
forgot all of them though I found some
of them amusing in the moment like all
his nicknames about a lion Ted Cruz and
then the rest you know
um but I do feel like she needs to um
yeah differentiate herself a bit more
but then also just keep her language
simple
Trump
was more complex than Bernie
um in his his literal language but he
was repetitive and there was kind of a
rhythm and a Cadence to Trump's speech I
think AOC needs to like Bernie reduce
her rhetoric down to a couple key lines
and signatures and focus her politics
not on 20 issues but on three or four
most important issues and have that
message this one Bernie will do an
interview with you and he'll write down
hope you do interview Bernie
um but me too he'll write down like five
things and like yeah I'm only gonna talk
about these five things yeah ask me
about this okay I'm talking about these
five things so that's a message
discipline that Bernie has been
exemplary on yeah yeah for sure so but I
think that's learned that could be
developed I think she could develop it
listen I hope I'm answering your
question I think not the way I should
answer it being someone you know
broadcasting to
um to people on the on the left and and
and and and and and you know elsewhere
um I hope AOC goes in that direction I
just think that she has a lot going
against her just because she's already a
national figure
and choosing a deeper blue District but
but we need to root our politics then in
Working Class People and a lot of
districts that I don't know the the type
of kitchen table conversations are I
hate that cliche but I just used it but
a lot of these these conversations are
just different in their tone and Cadence
and it's not just a question of I you
know fetterman or Tim Ryan in Ohio and
kind of just white working class voters
I mean working class voters of any race
um there's their day-to-day needs and
the day-to-day things they want to talk
about is just at a different plane than
you know uh a Met Gala cultural
statement
yeah I mean it's clear that your respect
and lover and and would like to see uh
different ways I mean she's young so the
different trajectories that she could
develop that would ultimately uh make
her a good candidate I'm just looking
odds here for and I disagree with them
I'm buying AOC stock here given these
odds so uh in terms of democratic who's
going to win the 2024 election so that
includes running and winning uh on the
Democrat side is 18 chance for Biden
seven percent chance for Kamala Harris
Gavin Newsom at six percent Michelle
Obama at uh three percent Hillary
Clinton at two percent and AOC at 1.5
percent and then Bernie at one percent
so uh I would not buy AOC at that Mark I
would buy Biden like crazy though I'm
not a Gambling Man but I would I would
totally toss a toss a g at Biden at that
amount I always say 1.5 chance I think
it's I think it's I don't think she runs
um you don't think she runs yeah okay I
don't think Bernie will primary Biden
either I mean he Eddie Biden doesn't run
then obviously it's an open field